[Music]
on this Wednesday night Ontario sounds
the alarm why is the province with the
most people doing the fewest tests for
Kovac 19 it's unacceptable
Alberta's stern warning it all depends
on how Albertans act in the weeks to
come
the Premier's plan to ramp up testing
there bolster the battered economy and
better screen international travelers as
calls multiply for improved checks at
the canada-us border they're not graves
relaxing the rules about the emergency
wage subsidy even more companies are now
eligible and post pandemic preparations
a top Canadian doctor on what needs to
happen to ease us out of this
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we all continue to endure
unprecedented restrictions on every
aspect of our lives pressure is mounting
to increase kovat 19 testing in this
country until now tests have mostly been
restricted to people with symptoms and
those who have been in close contact
with an infected person and Ontario has
been lagging far behind it has done
fewer tests per capita than most other
provinces it has the ability we're told
to test 13,000 people a day over the
last 10 days the most it's done is
between 6,000 to fewer than 3000 tests a
day it's unacceptable we say we can do
13,000 a day then we need to start doing
13,000 every single day the days are
done of these two and 3,000 a day being
tested we have to make this happen and
we need to start doing it immediately
starting tomorrow that's premier Doug
Ford now testing was limited at the
start of this pandemic because of a lack
of supplies and lab capacity everywhere
but that since ramped up and now there's
intense pressure to test a much wider
group starting with frontline health
care workers and employees and residents
in long-term care facilities Global's
Travis dhanraj's with me from Toronto
Travis Doug Ford is fired up about this
why has Ontario been so slow to ramp up
testing well it's a very good question
Donna and you could hear the frustration
in the Premier's voice today he said
that he spoke with the Cova Dean command
table that they have here in Toronto and
he spoke to health officials right
across the province really saying that
he wants this testing ramped up now
initially the problem was we didn't have
enough reagent that there weren't enough
assessment centers that problem as he
mentioned has been fixed so now what
health officials are saying is
essentially that there is a backlog from
those first tests that needed to be done
that they need to get through first they
also need to give we reintroduce new
guidelines for testing to public health
units now we know that the premier has
said that he wants long-term care
residents and also long-term care
workers tested and we saw how
desperately those tests are needed
day at a facility here in Toronto
long-term care facilities Sevenoaks
there were a hundred patients that are
either confirmed or presumptive cases of
kovat 19 and almost a dozen or so
healthcare workers in that facility so
the premier says that no more excuses
that this testing has to be ramped up
but only time will tell in the next
couple of days whether or not that
becomes a reality Donna all right Travis
Dhanraj in Toronto thanks
Alberta's premier also wants to
seriously ramp up testing there and take
a much more rigorous approach to
tracking returning travelers who were
under mandatory orders to self isolate
Jason Kenney is aiming for 20,000 tests
a day and he says he believes it was a
mistake for Canada to wait so long to
close the borders especially to
countries with high levels of infection
Tom Vernon is with me from the Alberta
legislature in Edmonton Tom what's
behind the tough new message from
premier Kenny yeah Donna premier candy
says here in Alberta we're really facing
a triple threat there's obviously the
public health concern when it comes to
kovat 19 and the economic downturn being
caused by that pandemic but Alberta is
also facing a collapse in world oil
prices which is compounding the economic
issues here now you mentioned he had
concerns about returning international
travelers he raised these concerns last
month as well he says Alberta will
provide more resources to track and
quarantine and test these people as they
come back although he hasn't said
exactly what that will look like on the
quarantine to enforce that the premier
has also suggested the idea of using
cell phone technology to ensure
quarantine orders are being followed
that's obviously raised some privacy
concerns here in Alberta but the premier
says these measures are for and as we
learn more details is truly to stop the
spread of the virus
we simply cannot risk letting the virus
loose in Alberta that would create a
public health catastrophe which would
force an even more stringent lockdown in
the future leaving our economy even
further battered Tom the premier is also
warning of 25 percent unemployment in
Alberta and of paying some companies to
take Alberta's oil what's his strategy
to try to mitigate what he calls the
greatest challenge of a generation
yeah Donna that 25% unemployment number
he gave that to a business audience
yesterday that would add up to about
500,000 Albertans out of work so some of
the steps the province is suggesting
while he said in his speech last night
that it's placing much of the blame on
Saudi Arabia and Russia they have to do
what take a lot of the effort and
reducing that amount to supply of oil on
the market but he said there more needs
to be done to supply North American
energy security work on that front
another step premier candy pointed to
was Alberta's investments in the
Keystone XL pipeline and getting that
project moving forward he says that will
provide long-term stability here in
Alberta opposition members here are
quick to point out though that the
Premier's vision is too narrow he needs
to look wider than just oil and gas he
needs to start talking more about
diversification Donna Tom Vernon in
Edmonton thanks well the number of
Canadians confirmed to have kovat 19 is
changing rapidly here are the latest
numbers more than 1300 new cases were
reported today most of them in Ontario
in Quebec with today's jump Quebec now
has more than 10,000 confirmed cases
Ontario has just over 5200 overall more
than 19,000 people in Canada are known
to have the virus though we know of
course many people have not been tested
yet at least 430 people have died in
Canada Global News has learned there are
no public health officers at land border
crossings to test people for the virus
it's a gap in screening that potentially
puts people at risk and it raises
questions about whether there's enough
monitoring and enforcement at the border
to detect and track people who are
coming back from overseas
Mercedes Stevenson joins me now Mercedes
BC did announce a crackdown on screening
today what can you tell us well the
premier John Horgan was out and he is
telling people that they're not just
expected to self isolate they're
actually going to have to show a plan
when they get to the airport or come
across that border crossing saying here
is how I am going to self isolate if
they are not satisfied but the plan that
is presented which will be treated as a
legal document then they will have a
plan for you and force you into
isolation that means they are concerned
obviously that people are coming across
and presenting self-isolation plans
either aren't
sticking to them or they're not
realistic take a listen to what he had
to say earlier this afternoon they will
be met by BC officials they'll be met by
federal officials and they will be
required to explain in detail with forms
that will be provided on flights forms
that are also available on the web to
ensure that these legal documents are
completed upon arrival and that a plan
has been put in place Donna
there have been inconsistent
applications at different border
crossings and in different provinces of
these quarantine orders and of the
self-isolation
one of the things we learned is that
there are no public health officers at
land border crossings this despite the
fact that publicly the government is
saying when you cross the border if you
say you have symptoms you will be
referred to a public health officer but
they are not there and the vast majority
of people coming into Canada are coming
through those border crossings that's
creating a lot of concern for frontline
border officers who want to have someone
who they can actually refer people to
who are an expert in this Marcedes
Health Canada apparently warned that
that this tracking of returning
travelers would be an issue what do we
know about that that's right so in
document says about a thousand pages of
them that were tabled at the Health
Committee there is advice from public
health officials to the minister warning
that they didn't even have the resources
to be able to track and enforce a
quarantine order against people coming
back from mainland China let alone
around the world and we have that quote
for you we can put it up there you can
see that the federal health officials
said that if this approach were to be
extended to China it would be
unsustainable given the volume of
travellers Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
was asked about why they didn't put more
resources into Public Health if they
were receiving warnings that early about
the difficulty tracking people this is
what he had to say earlier today with
hindsight I'm sure there are lots of
things that we would have done
differently could have done differently
but I can tell you that every step of
the way
we took the advice of our medical
professionals and our public health
experts and Marcedes you've got some
information about kovat 19 potentially
being weaponized by terrorist groups and
others what have we learned about that
so Donna as you know intelligence
agencies are always trying to figure out
every
possible scenario so this isn't to
suggest that there's an imminent attack
or that is just around the corner but
the RCMP has been forwarding a memo from
the United States Department of Homeland
Security who they got it from written up
by railways in the u.s. warning that
some violent extremist groups might try
to exploit holes and security around
hospitals and grocery stores where
there's lineups of people at this time
terrorism experts are saying that the
virus has disrupted terror groups as
well as everyone else but they are
nonetheless keeping a careful eye on
this the RCMP says they're always
tracking these kinds of threats to be
careful with it and of course they're
watching as well for frontline officers
and military who some groups are trying
to encourage people to cough in their
faces as a way to spread this
fortunately it's hard to know if you're
infected with kovat 19 and if you are it
may not be well enough to go and do that
Donna all right Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thanks
well the restrictions that are shut down
the economy are really starting to hit
home now and today the criteria for the
federal emergency wage subsidy program
was relaxed to qualify businesses now
only need to show a 15% decline in
revenue in March instead of a 30%
decline in overall revenue charities can
choose whether to include government
subsidies when calculating their loss of
revenue and when it comes to students
the government is going to cover 100
percent of wages for those hired under
the Canada summer jobs program there are
more broad changes too but as Michael
Couture reports there are still some
gaps
it doesn't feel very regal but this
takeout window is the only way the King
Eddy diner can stay in business owner
Jonathan bonny isn't sure if he can use
the government's wage subsidy program
being able to project revenues that you
know will allow for us to you know make
those forecasts and say like yeah I
think we can you know hire back some
some of our employees
it does have some time since the program
still needs parliamentary approval get
moving a little less conversation a
little more action please evoking the
image of Elvis conservatives are calling
on the government to speed up the
process the Prime Minister emerged from
his own social shutdown Wednesday to
chair a cabinet meeting on the agenda
was the federal Kovan 19 modeling data
and when Parliament will reconvene to
pass the wage subsidy bill which Justin
Trudeau admits has some shortfalls what
we've talked about over these past days
is ways of filling those gaps and making
sure that more people who are in
exceptional or different circumstances
are able to access the help we need
rushing a program of this size could
mean a lack of checks and balances so
the government is hoping to dissuade
anyone anyone caught abusing the program
could face penalties up to two hundred
and twenty five percent of what they've
received and up to five years in prison
significant penalties to protect a
program that the Deputy Prime Minister
says will allow the country's economy to
quote come roaring back this is gonna
maintain that essential connection
between people and their jobs and it is
gonna help businesses remain fully
functional and intact
to that end air canada announced its
rehiring 16,000 previously laid off
employees the airline CEO says the wage
subsidy program will help keep workers
on board until the economy is ready to
take off again Donna okay Mike ligature
in Ottawa thank you we are getting a
better sense of how many Canadians have
been laid off work cannot work because
of this pandemic since Monday more than
1.7 million people have applied for the
federal assistance program that Canada
emergency response benefit
and since March 15 the government says
more than 4.2 million people have either
applied for the CRB or for employment
insurance a number of people including
some accused of serious crimes are being
released from correctional facilities in
Canada which are at high risk of Kovach
19 outbreaks some judges have cited the
increased risk in the close quarters of
detention centers as a factor in their
decisions to grant bail
Canada's court system is shut down
except for emergency cases right now and
there will be a backlog when normal
operations resume it's not clear when
trials for some of the people being held
in cats in custody will begin you can
read the full story by globals Stewart
belet's on our website Global News CA /
global national crowdsourcing the corona
virus pandemic coming up a Canadian
doctors call-to-action
in the UK new cases of Kovac 19 are
beginning to decline but the death toll
is out of control 938 people died in the
last 24 hours
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson
himself is still not out of intensive
care though as crystal commencing
explains his condition is said to be
improving the world is waiting and
watching the hope is that Boris Johnson
will walk out of this London hospital
but is not there yet
the latest from the hospital is that the
Prime Minister remains in intensive care
where his condition is improving I can
also tell you that he has been sitting
up in bed and engaging positively with
the clinical team Johnson has now been
in hospital in the ICU for two nights he
was admitted Sunday evening at the time
he said it was just precautionary he
needed a few tests I have a temperature
the Prime Minister is not known to have
any pre-existing conditions the 55 year
old was diagnosed about two weeks ago
he's one of more than 60,000 who have
been infected in the UK the news about
the PM reminds us how indiscriminate
this disease is nearly everyone will
know someone who's been affected friends
family neighbors colleagues kovat 19 has
led to the deaths of more than 7,000
people here an emergency meeting will
take place Thursday to discuss the
lockdown with the PM still in the ICU
his designate will be taking the lead
crystal the Man Singh Global News London
still ahead the Canadians using
crowdsourcing to try to save lives
without more testing we won't know the
true extent of kovat 19 infection now a
Canadian doctor is hoping crowdsourcing
might help Jeff simple explains there's
growing evidence and concern that kovat
19 might be hiding in people with no or
very mild symptoms I don't have any
underlying health issues
others like Kyla Lee in Vancouver have
symptoms but were never tested I was
advised by the doctor that unless it
gets to the point where I'm essentially
breathing like this all the time not
teeth then consider going to a hospital
testing is severely lacking right we
don't have a great handle what's
happening community this Canadian
professor at Harvard Medical School just
launched this website kovat near you
mapping confirmed and suspected cases by
asking people to self-report what if we
just ask people how they're feeling
could we get insights into what's X in
ways that we can ever the website asks
users in North America to type in their
postal code and from there you can see
reported cases of kovat 19 in your area
as well as others who've tested negative
or are showing symptoms consistent with
the virus even healthy people are being
asked to input their data which will
then be used anonymously by researchers
to track the spread getting the actual
true sense and true idea of how many
cases are all around the country will
give us a better idea of where this
pandemic is headed another company is
taking self reporting a step further
starting next week any confirmed cases
on Vancouver Island will be asked to
share their recent contacts with this
software all of those people will then
automatically be sent this email or text
message alert asking them if they've
developed any symptoms of the virus and
if so to list their contacts from the
past couple of weeks so it spreads
naturally and kind of build out a tree
all from patient zero to whether it's a
dozen people they came into contact with
or hundreds it's scales infinitely
crowdsourcing the fight against kovat 19
your home your Netflix and chilling you
maybe try to Cove it and chill a little
bit be part of a public health
surveillance system you know you it's a
few seconds to actually you know really
you know provide some data to support
Canada its fight against coronavirus
just simple Global News Toronto next
learning from a Canadian doctors
international experience this virus
waits for no one and when it hits there
is little time for doctors to do much
other than try to save as many lives as
possible dr. Joanne Lee you knows what
it's like to be on the front lines of an
emergency she spent five years as head
of Doctors Without Borders now she's
back working at a hospital in Montreal
Mike Armstrong spoke with her doctor
Joanne Leo says there were lessons
learned fighting Ebola outbreaks in
Africa and one is that the margin for
error fighting covered 19 is thin
there's there's no forgiveness in
pandemic there's just no forgiveness and
most of the time that cost is life our
Syrian colleagues are there for the
duration dr. Leo headed up Doctors
Without Borders for six years the
organization has more than 36,000
employees working in about 70 countries
when her mandate wrapped up last year
the plan was to write a book but now
with her old colleagues at Montreal's
st. Just's in hospital battling kovat 19
she's put the writing on hold many of my
colleague and many people in this sector
they're scared and they're right to be
scared you has been disappointed in the
shortages of protective gear asking
doctors and nurses and orderlies to do
their jobs without the necessary PPE she
says isn't fair it also sets the entire
system up for failure
if we don't want our health care system
to follow knees knee over the next few
weeks we're going to need a health care
workforce healthy not infected one of
the procedures Liew suggests for
hospitals is the use of spotters
putting on and taking off PPE is
dangerous and the person wearing it is
often tired Doctors Without Borders has
someone walking the worker through each
step they
of this do that but he was the way that
we made sure that we're not getting
infected after the immediate concerns
leo is also worried about down the road
what happens when this winds down
post-traumatic stress is going to be an
issue and not only for health care
workers everyone on the frontlines from
grocery store clerks to bus drivers
needs help I think this should be a
hotline I think people should be able to
debrief about their fear they should be
able to have that kind of support 24/7
kovat 19 may attack the lungs but leo
says governments have to worry about
both body and mind
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal and
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna freeze and we know
faith sustains many of you especially in
times of crisis Easter is this weekend
and Passover begins tonight and the
message to everyone everywhere is revise
your rituals avoid large gatherings even
Jerusalem is under lockdown tonight
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]